aoc's turning on Joe Biden the Socialist
squad leader furiously slamming the
president's border wall U-turn which has
him building 20 new miles of barrier in
Texas Biden continues to say that walls
don't work but he had no choice the big
bad republicans in Congress tied his
hands and forced him to build it but AOC
says that excuse ain't going to cut it
quote the president needs to take
responsibility for this decision and
reverse course walls only serve to push
migrants into more remote areas
increasing their chances of death it is
a cruel policy AOC is also airing her
grievances from her couch it's a
terrible idea I think it's a broken
promise but additionally let's say you
completely disagree on
this you could build a great big trumpy
wall on the entire us Southern border
and it's still not going to fix this
problem the US and US foreign policy is
contributing
to the displacement of millions of
people in South America to begin with
and if we do not address the migrant
crisis at its root it is still going to
continue to be a
problem wait judge did she just get to
the root causes yeah she should call up
kamla I mean the root Pro uh the causes
are that the US foreign policy is
contributing to people trying to get
into the United States this is so crazy
look Joe Biden when he's asked why did
you do this he said I was told I had no
choice so the president of the United
States isn't really willing to explain
anything and K Jean Pierre says he is
complying with the law which requires
him to build a wall so the people in The
Press said well what law is that wh who
who where does it say he's got to build
the wall and Kar jier says well I don't
know call the Department of Justice I'm
not a lawyer they don't even know why
they know why because they're they're on
the bottom in terms of the polls but I
think the the interesting thing about
all this is that uh they made a decision
people on the left like AOC are Furious
so he's now in a tough situation because
the progressives who helped get him in
are now furious with him so to me he
can't reconcile the two he can't say
well here's the law I had to do it and
now by the way the the Venezuelans
470,000 of them were welcome two weeks
ago we were getting them all work
permits now he's going to start
deporting them either he's a
schizophrenic or had a labotomy I don't
know which one it is but here's the
bottom line point the bottom line is
this Joe Biden because he is angering
the progressives because his numbers are
so bad they've got to move from the left
he's not going to be running it for
president they're going to put somebody
else in he can't make the two ends meet
he's go he's a goner now Jessica do you
believe that's the reason we're seeing
record migration is because United
States is meddling in Latin America
which we have been doing for what
hundreds of years I I think that people
in a postco world or towards the end and
now postco are picking up in the numbers
in terms of coming in are certainly
making the journey what happened with
title 42 has to do with it um that Co
well Co certainly had an effect on mass
migration all over the world not just
here with our Southern border um the
policy though that Biden's talking about
is the 2019 rule that Congress passed so
it's congress's job to do this Biden
says we tried to reappropriate the funds
they wouldn't let us do it but I do
think that there's hidden benefits to
this remember when the courts kept
saying that title 42 had to be extended
so the Biden Administration could say
it's not us we don't want it but it
ended up being something that was kind
of stying migration a little bit so this
might have kind of like the backhanded
benefit but Biden should really consider
embracing I'm not saying going as far as
deporter and chief but both Bill Clinton
and Barack Obama had reputations for
being quite harsh about the border and
it didn't hurt them electorally they
both got resoundingly reelected and that
is an option here and the fact that
people like mayor Adams are heading down
to the Border um what's going on in
Chicago DC and everyone is apoplectic
about it you might want to embrace being
a little bit harsher about it and just
own it you remember when you were
bragging a couple months ago that Biden
reduced illegal immigration I remember I
remember that I I remember you were
spiking the football he fixed the
problem
I said that there was an app Kenedy yeah
the app's broken it got hacked by the
cartels Kennedy okay so there are a
number of things going on here AOC God
if only she knew someone in Congress
because we have a horrible imigration
system we also have awful border
security those are two separate things
but liberals like to just talk about
immigration and border security as
though border security and offense is so
inhumane well a bad immigration system
is also inhumane and it is also so
complicated and so bureaucratic it's
impossible for people to immigrate to
this country legally it is so much
easier to go to Mexico or go to Honduras
or or El Salvador go through Mexico and
come into this country because you can
pretty much work anywhere the system is
set up for that uh what I love is in New
York City we have a congresswoman who
represents part of New York City and the
mayor of New York City at odds on this
very issue it is not up to the there to
determine federal policy it is up to the
federal government but they have
completely uh given up their
responsibility to protect this country
and to protect this city so now places
like California including Los Angeles
and San Francisco and New York have to
rethink what it means to be a sanctuary
City because that is something they said
in words they never intended for this to
happen and to have the welfare state
completely overrun because you cannot
have a broken immigration system that
leads to open borders and a massive
welfare state it is mathematically
unsustainable Greg Gutfeld when you see
a politician lay down on the couch and
explain things to you does that make you
more convinced or less uh I don't know I
got sleepy though I wanted some hot
cocoa I want to I do want to know what
the root cause is but more important I
want to know if she really wants to know
what the root cause is because I think I
know what it is these people that are
coming here prefer this evil
capitalistic racist country the country
that people like AOC just trash every
single day and you know why they like
this country cuz it's better too bad
what you're seeing is their Progressive
luxury beliefs implode Before Their Eyes
before the buses she could pantomime her
phony sorrow at the border and virtue
signal over Sanctuary cities but now
that her constituents are being affected
illegal immigrants are everywhere in New
York City they're in public spaces
they're using public Public Services
they're even taking jobs which actually
for cheaper they're taking jobs for
cheaper pay that's happening right now
that's got to be affecting the voters in
her in her uh area until they address
you know until they address the Border
they got to keep sending him sending him
send him to aoc's Turf send him to her
street the only way we get to the point
where the Democrats act and act whether
it's politically or morally it's hard to
tell is if they feel the consequences of
Their Own policies so I say I mean this
was a stroke of Genius and it's working
because now you're finally getting these
people to the table the next step is
whether or not they're going to agree
that assimilation is is is good or evil
because remember if you want to come
here you should want to assimilate
because you love this country you need
to leave your flag behind right you
don't come in and plant your flag you
have to come here and say I love this
place I want to know why this place is
so great but if you say that that means
that somehow you know that's our country
is preferable to theirs and that's
racist do you think AOC could say that
the United States is better than
Venezuela you think no no that's not we
just different countries yeah different
countries okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else